mais d'abord donc les annonces de jean
castex ce que l'état français déploie
pour accueillir les réfugiés ukrainien
avec fabien rey caire ils sont désormais
26000 ukrainien arrivée sur le sol
français depuis le début de la guerre
c'est ce qu'a annoncé jean castex cet
après midi à l'issue d'une réunion
interministérielle place beauvau notre
premier sujet est bien sûr celui de
l'accueil et de la berd l'hébergement
deux de ces personnes je voudrais
souligner le formidable élan de
solidarité de générosité des français
eux-mêmes puisque 91 mille places
d'hébergement particuliers ont été
proposées à ce jour d'ores et déjà nous
venons cet après-midi d'adopter un
schéma national d'accueil et
d'hébergement
proposant au moins cent mille places
d'hébergement pour nos amis ukrainiens
des réfugiés qui se voit accorder un
statut de protection temporaire par
l'union européenne à ce jour la france a
ainsi accordé 10500 autorisation de
séjour le gouvernement insiste sur
l'accompagnement des réfugiés plus de
2400 enfants ukrainiens sont déjà
accueillies dans les écoles et 8000
places vont être proposés dans les
universités d'après le haut commissaire
aux réfugiés des nations unies plus de
trois millions et demi de personnes ont
désormais fui l'ukraine aulas quel
accueil à long terme pour ces familles
pour ces réfugiés ukrainien quel impact
sur la campagne présidentielle française
les deux grands thèmes de ce débat avec
iam sur ou bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
philosophe très lente de l'association
pierre clavère qui se consacre à
l'intégration des réfugiés en france par
l'enseignement de la langue et de la
culture française pierre henry bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
le président de france fraternité
j'accueille également gérard françois
dumont géographe professeur à
l'université paris sorbonne directeur de
l'ars viola site de la revue je vais
trop vite population et avenir et vous
publiez géographie des populations c'est
aux éditions armand colin j'accueille
également en duplex
l'avis de robert qui est le directeur
général de singapore france bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi en soi et lætitia
cru pas éditorialistes politiques vont
soir laetitia à mes côtés comme tous les
mardis et jeudis et vous serez là aussi
demain voilà la france est elle à la
hauteur de cette crise migratoire c'est
le premier thème que je vous propose
d'aborder avant de vous entendre ce
sondage publié par pour france
télévision réalisée par ipsos et sopra
steria 83% des français répondent oui à
la question faut-il accueillir des
réfugiés d'ukrainiens en france et puis
ces chiffres je les rappelle fourni par
le gouvernement vingt-six mille
personnes déjà recensé c'est ce que jean
castex annoncé tout à l'heure et puis
cette capacité d'accueil à cent mille
réfugiés iam sureau comment je vouvoyais
écouté avec attention le premier
ministre comment vous réagissez en
entendant ces chiffres et ces mots
employés par le par jean castex
la réalité et est extraordinaire les
mots de monsieur castex sûrement aussi
mais la réalité est plus extraordinaires
je crois qu'on ne peut pas ne pas saluer
l'élan très inattendu des français c'est
nous sommes au sortir d'une crise de
pandémie on nous avons nous avons
calculé chaque geste appris la prudence
elle sert à deux années de ça deux
années de masques de deux solitudes
d'isolement de méfiance etc nous sommes
au milieu d'une campagne électorale
où énormément
2 de peur hante était donc remuer de
manière assez assez dégoûtante
et en fait les français sortent
parfaitement indemne de deux ans
d'épidémie et de cette campagne ils ont
ils ont montré une
en fait un art comment dire une vertu
une fraternité absolument extraordinaire
et spontanément et mat il faut d'abord
la saluer il a fallu remercie les 91 me
disent qu'ils ont simplement merveilleux
et il n'y a rien d'autre à dire que ça
c'est merveilleux maintenant ce que dit
le premier ministre sûrement aussi c'est
ça son schéma national c'est que une
fois que c'est elle en national et là
une fois que la société civile à
exprimer quelque chose il s'agit pour
les associations pour le gouvernement
d'accompagner de soutenir d'aider la
société civile et on va y revenir
évidemment ce serait nécessaire bien sûr
bien sûr pierre henri seux ce
mouvement-là ses 91 mille français qui
se sont proposés pour accueillir des
répudier ukrainien est ce que la france
a la capacité d'accueil j'allais dire
sans eux nous on en est nos capacités
d'accueil des réfugiés est ce qu'il y
avait de la place
d'abord je crois qu'effectivement il
faut saluer à la fois l'émotion qui
s'est emparée
2d des opinions publiques européennes à
la suite de l'invasion rouge
et puis il faut examiner réellement ce
qu'est cette mobilisation 91000
proposition de logement c'est beaucoup
maintenant il faut aller regarder de
près quelle est la qualité véritablement
de ces logements surtout si par malheur
le conflit devait durer
aujourd'hui vous avez un dispositif
national d'accueil qui prend en charge
aussi bien demandeurs d'asile que
réfugiés de toutes nationalités qui fait
plus de cent mille places et qui est
totalement saturée et donc si
la guerre devait durer ainsi la voie
diplomatique n'a même pas à un
cessez le feu et un retour et population
sans doute saurions-nous devant de
grandes difficultés
tout simplement parce que
aujourd'hui je rappelle que la france
accueille dix fois moins de réfugiés
craignant que l'allemagne elle en
accueille vingt fois moins que la
moldavie donc aujourd'hui
la mobilisation correspond en gros au
nombre d'arrivées demain si la crise
devait perdurer nous pourrions être en
difficulté et ça supposerait d'autres
mesures de la part du gouvernement qui
jusqu'ici réagi évidemment très bien
tout comme la société civile j'ai un
françois dumont il faut effectivement
vous l'avez évoqué mais peut-être le
détail ce sont d'abord les pays les plus
proches de l'ukraine qui qui portent le
voile a le poids de cette solidarité
aujourd'hui d'abord la baule
d'abord est tout simplement en raison de
la proximité c'est à dire toujours quand
il y à un exode de populations à les
populations quittent leur territoire
pour aller vers le premier territoire où
ils pensent que leur sécurité est
assurée donc leur survie possible ça
c'est la première raison la seconde
raison c'est l'importance de la
géographie des diasporas il faut quand
même préciser que l'ukraine est un pays
qui avait 51 millions d'habitants 1990
qui n'en a plus que 41 millions à la
veille dans le temps un pays qui se
vident la population avant la guerre
vidée de sa population
parce que malheureusement elle ne
parvenait pas à un bon développement
économique pour prendre un exemple
simple la pologne en 1990 le niveau
économique de la pologne et de l'ukraine
semblables aujourd'hui le niveau
économique de la pologne trois fois plus
élevé que celui de l'ukraine donc les
gens partaient pas ce qui désespéraient
dans le développement économique de leur
pays et donc nous avions des millions
d'ukrainiens qui était à l'étranger
notamment bien sûr en pologne et donc
effectivement là pour la première vague
j'irai que l'accueil a été toutes choses
égales par ailleurs bien sûr plus simple
dans la mesure où la première vague ce
sont des personnes qui ont rejoint des
membres de leur population dt déjà à
l'étranger et puis maintenant nous
arrivons dans une deuxième vague c'est à
dire avec des ukrainiens qui n'ont aucun
référent à l'étranger ni un frère et un
cousin indiens voisins et c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué est ce qu'il va être
encore plus complexe c'est nous avons eu
dans l'histoire d'autres exode de
populations ou c'étaient des familles
entières qui partait mais là en réalité
comme vous le savez ce sont les mamans
leurs enfants et les personnes âgées et
les hommes adultes de 18 à 60 ans reste
en ukraine pour combattre contre
l'invasion donc d'un point de vue
psychologique nous avons fait des
familles séparées donc il faut
évidemment s'occuper de leur accueil
matériel comme cela a été très très très
bien dit mais il faut aussi prendre en
compte toutes ses dimensions
psychologiques qui est très difficile à
prendre en compte puisque ce sont des
familles dans les maris pour être simple
sont au combat
david robert le tournoi avait vers vous
thing as et c'est une organisation
mondiale et qui aident les réfugiés a
trouvé du travail à créer leur
entreprise et ils sont très nombreux à
le faire à trouver évidemment à un
logement en accord avec les populations
locales c'est vraiment le coeur de votre
de votre activité quels conseils vous
donnez là on dont on a tous réagi à ce
chiffre de 91 mille français quels
conseils vous leur donnez c'est à
imaginer c'est un engagement peut-être
de plus longue durée que ce que est ce
qui me gêne il imagine aujourd'hui
exactement merci
tout l'enjeu c'est de faire en sorte de
faire durer cette mobilisation citoyenne
d'une façon assez je pense facilement
compréhensible une mobilisation
citoyenne à quelqu'un qui ouvre sa porte
pendant plusieurs mois va avoir beaucoup
plus d'impact que plusieurs personnes
qui ouvrent leurs portes pendant
quelques jours ou quelques semaines
tout l'enjeu des programmes d'accueil
qu'on a développé chez l'habitant déjà
il faut remettre les choses dans leur
contexte l'accueil chez l'habitant c'est
quelque chose qui prend du temps c'est
quelque chose qui n'a de valeur que si
c'est effectivement sur le temps long
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
fort dans la mesure où ça développe le
réseau social autour de la personne
accueillie et puis cela change aussi la
posture de l'accueillant sa part mieux
comprendre ce qu'est la migration ce
qu'elle accueille dans un pays c'est
bénéfique pour tout le monde à condition
d'être sur du long terme par rapport au
dispositif d'hébergement traditionnel il
faut garder en tête que la cloche chez
l'habitant ce sera quelques milliers de
places pendant un an ce qui est
effectivement quand on parle d'une place
d'hébergement on en parle pendant une
certaine durée il faut comprendre que on
doit compter un peu de la même manière
sur des places chez l'habitant pour
mettre bout à bout des moments chez
l'habitant c'est important d'avoir
effectivement un délai plus long
possible on préconise aux familles
accueillantes de ne s'engager qu'à
partir de 3 mois minimum c'est très
important pour la personne de retrouver
une stabilité et aussi parce que c'est
en étant chez l'habitant longtemps qu'on
pourra avoir une sortie vers l'emploi
vers le logement autonome effectivement
plus durable plus pérenne et si l'enjeu
pour nous mais là chez l'habitant faut
garder en tête que c'est une petite
proportion de disponibilité du schéma
national d'accueil réagir pas évident ce
temps long c'est contre intuitif à moi
j'aurais dit plutôt que cet accueil
comme ça spontané c'est vrai qu'on en a
tous autour de nous peut être nous mêmes
sommes accueillants et plutôt un accueil
d'urgence enfin on pourrait s'imaginer
que c'est un accueil spontané d'urgence
pour justement une solution de long
terme après alors je vais vous donner la
parole parce que vous avez notre
expertise nous nous nous importe mais je
reste avec david robert là-dessus serre
que est-ce que vous dans les premiers
retours que vous avez c'est plutôt des
propositions effectivement d'accueil
cours en urgence qui reviennent vers
vous on a les deux les gens qui nous
connaissent déjà parce qu'on est on
était un peu le programme référence
d'accueil chez l'habitant nous
contactent plutôt pour du long terme
donc là on est exactement dans ce qu'on
cherchait à avoir
après ce qu'il faut comprendre pour
savoir pourquoi c'est effectivement un
peu contre intuitif online est tout à
fait c'est sa pierre henry quelle
expérience de france terre d'asile avec
il a dirigé pendant de nombreuses années
pour la raconter
quand on fait rentrer quelqu'un dans un
dispositif d'hébergement quel qu'il soit
il faut aussi prévoir cette sortie est
donc en fait faire rentrer quelques cas
chez l'habitant pour trois semaines
c'est finalement de répondre qu'un tout
petit moment du besoin est d'où
l'intérêt de trouver des dispositifs
qu'il soit collectif ou individuel les
dispositifs d'hébergement qu'ils soient
effectivement sur du plus long terme et
donc c'est contre intuitif on sait qu'il
ya une grande proportion de personnes
qui s'apprêtent à accueillir quelques
semaines et qu'on va essayer de
sensibiliser
convaincre en disant votre élan de
générosité il est magnifique il est
absolument magique et maintenant
peut-être prenez un peu plus votre temps
pour réfléchir et pour pouvoir
accueillir plusieurs mois au lieu de
plusieurs semaines parce que vous allez
voir beaucoup plus d'impact et aussi
vous allez avoir sans doute une
colocation plus riche et plus belle à la
fin c'est important de préparer ce que
je retiens ce que vient de dire que la
sortie quoi c'est là aussi ça on peut
dire c'est contre intuitif on est
généreux on accueille du monde mais il
faut déjà se préparer au moment et pour
partir et je partage totalement ce qui
vient d'être dis parce que tout
simplement si vous accueillez les
personnes sur la distance au delà de
l'hébergement d'urgence d'un toit sur la
tête de pouvoir se nourrir derrière et
il y à des questions beaucoup plus
lourde l'accès à un logement l'accès à
un emploi parlé la langue du pays
d'accueil donc ça je suppose des
compétences que les personnes n'ont pas
forcément l'âge et au delà de la
générosité il y a
à se débattre avec les administrations
ça prend énormément de temps il ya
l'aspect psychologique que vous
soulignez tout à l'heure autrement dit
c'est une prise de relais par les
professionnels mais attention il s'agit
pas du tout de dire aux personnes qui
aujourd'hui voudraient se mobiliser de
ne pas le faire il s'agit simplement
d'attirer l'attention des autorités
politiques de ce pays
aujourd'hui je le dis clairement nous ne
sommes pas prêts sur la durée
aujourd'hui nous avons répondu à un
besoin d'urgence et on le fait très très
bien mais si ce conflit doit durer alors
à partir de ce moment-là ça demandera
des moyens financiers des moyens humains
des moyens matériels d'hébergement
beaucoup plus important et puis vous
avez aussi d'autres aspects parce que
vous avez d un peu aussi un angle mort
dans cet accueil c'est vrai que pour la
première fois l'union européenne a mis
en place une mesure de protection
temporaire
pour tous les ukrainiens qui fuit les
bleus pour le détaillera dans un mais il
y a aussi des résidents étrangers
qui avaient des courts séjours en
ukraine et qui sont aujourd'hui en
france et qui ne bénéficient pas de
cette protection temporaire je pense par
exemple
un certain nombre d'étudiants qui
aujourd'hui peuvent toujours se rendre
dans les préfectures mais qui ressortent
sans titre ni droit ces questions là
vont se poser au fur et à mesure que
hélas la guerre va durer prenez
l'hypothèse d'une d'un exode ou voilà
qui va durer des années mais nul ne sait
si mais moi oui mais vous parler
d'emploi etc mais par exemple pour
l'association c'est déjà le cas les
enfants qui sont là en tout cas moi je
les ai vus dans les classes voilà qui
sont déjà sont en classe évidemment donc
ça se fait très rapidement finalement
dès leur arrivée surprise en place mais
dans comme vous le dites monsieur les
papas les hommes sont restés dans le
pays donc on peut imaginer qu on espère
que si une solution est trouvée les
familles espérons c'est quand même le
calcul il me semble que beaucoup de
politiques français en tout cas quand
ils en parlent ils pensent justement
ayem siro sur la question de l'éducation
j'aimerais bien vous entendre
l'importance il ya des choses de la
scolarisation des enfants mais même
aussi on l'a on l'a entendu ouvrir des
plus des places par exemple dans une
université parce qu'il ya déjà des
jeunes étudiants qui font partie de ces
familles qui arrivent en france oui
maintenant vous savez nous ne sommes pas
prêts c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas le droit de dire parce que la
guerre est donc
le dit non mais vous verrez ce que lire
nous ne devons pas nous donner le droit
de dire nous ne sommes pas prêts nous
devons nous rendre près voilà voyez nous
devons nous rendre près ce que l'on veut
à dire écoutez a arrêté tout tout de
suite nous ne sommes pas prêts c'est la
guerre
non mais nous ne sommes pas prêts je
n'entends autour de moi que des
récriminations contre à peu près tout le
monde là contre l'état qui n'étaient pas
préparés contre les personnes qui sont
d'une convocation excessive les tous les
volontaires qui ont pu accueillir des
ukrainiens chez eux faire la route
jusqu'à la pologne etc de manière assez
en effet évolutionnaire ému etc ceci est
c'est la vie c'est à nous d'accompagner
sa wii et non pas de juger ce qui a été
fait je suis je suis assez d'accord avec
ce que disait david robert key
qui s'établit à faire et singh à ce type
de volatilité c'est une organisation
assez étonnantes comme ça et qui peut
justement observer ce qui se passe les
ukrainiens sont logés chez des personnes
manière spontanée et donner des conseils
et d'accompagnement justement sur les
besoins sociaux la scolarisation le
danger de santé mentale le soutien
psychologique les traumas de guerre ce
genre de choses précisément à cause de
la volatilité ce nous devons le penser à
9 parce que nous n'avons nous avons un
petit peu en france perdu l'habitude de
réfugiés immédiat vous disiez les pays
proches
provenant d'une guerre en cours et donc
nous avons des habitudes d'action et des
habitudes de pensée qui ont doucement
été fait sur mesure pour des personnes
qui avaient quitté des conflits
plusieurs mois auparavant et qui venait
jusqu'à chez nous c'est à dire dix mille
kilomètres plus loin de chez eux c'est
pas limitrophes reconstruire une vie et
donc nous avons un accueil pour les
réfugiés et ça c'est un peu dans
l'esprit des institutions du
gouvernement il faut essayer de secouer
sa et de voir la situation et craignent
n2 phase d'intégration ça que nous
confondons l'asile avec un dispositif
d'intégration alors qu'il est aussi
c'est la définition du dictionnaire une
mise à l'abri est ce que j'ai vu les
écrits nien que j'ai pu voir c'était des
femmes accrochés sur leur téléphone
parce que leur fils de 18 ans et leur
mari est au front que leur maison leur
est tombé sur la gueule on l'a enflammée
etc et c'est une située situation où on
fait le logement pérenne
à apprendre le français et trouver un
travail est évidemment une question qui
risque de se poser dans la durée et le
moi je suis comme vous c'est à dire le
plus pessimiste possible comme comme
hypothèse de travail mais il faut
malheureusement penser l'instant
l'urgence que
où travaille d'abord l'urgence et en
actions effectivement il est important
de bien préciser que nous n'avons jamais
gérer ce genre d'événement prix c'est à
dire que dans le passé nous avons géré
des demandes d'asile nous avons géré un
certain nombre de sauvetages de
vietnamiens ont les années 75 79 d'y
aller quand tyler nous les boat people
mais cette aide est des situations où
nous accueillons des populations qu'ils
allaient définitivement s'implanter sur
le territoire français là c'est
évidemment par l'objectif de ces
populations et comme nous ne comme nous
ne l'avons jamais fait nous ne savons
pas le faire et nous ne savons pas le
faire notamment parce que nous avons des
réglementations beaucoup trop compliqué
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que à
supposer que malheureusement ce conflit
dure et que ces personnes doivent rester
à l'étranger plus longtemps que prévu
cela supposera forcément un certain
nombre de moyens matériels en matière
d'école en matière de logement en
matière d'accueil social or je tairai
les assume nous avons des
réglementations beaucoup trop complexe
et moi je dis que si ça dure il faut
absolument qu'ils aient des ordonnances
qui simplifie les règlementations pour
qu'on puisse mettre en place les
structures matérielles et humaines
susceptibles d'accueillir ces
populations et ben je vais poser cette
question là justement un élu un maire
vincent chauvet qui est maire d'autun en
étant en saône-et-loire cc autun ckoi
autour de 13 mille habitants c'est ça
c'est absolument si j'ai regardé en
préparant les missions est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
gérard françois dumont sur la la
complexité finalement
du cadre réglementaire de l'accueil des
réfugiés en france
alors il y appelait des irritants si on
veut notamment par exemple des choses
qu'on n'avait pas forcément prévu comme
les permis craignent un qui sont pas
reconnus en france et donc des gens qui
viennent avec leur voiture en théorie
alors être conduire en france mais moi
je sors à l'instant d'une réunion
interministérielle avec joël giraud et
marlène schiappa il ya une foire aux
questions faq qui a été mise en ligne et
tout s'est tu toutes ces points sont en
train d'être d'être traités avec une
rapidité assez étonnante la ville
d'ottawa était très impliqué dans les
années précédentes sur l'accueil de
réfugiés syriens et de famille neziri
réfugiés irakienne c'était un peu plus
long on était sur des programmes de
réinstallation il y avait des certaines
choses qui allaient plus vite notamment
la mobilisation des logements du parc
social il y avait aussi certaines choses
qui prenait quasiment un an il ya bien
un an d'accompagnement pour ces familles
et notamment d'accompagnement
administratif là en une semaine ils ont
un statut qui leur permet de travailler
d'avoir une couverture sociale minimale
de pouvoir prétendre aux aides au
logement et d'avoir une existence légale
en france pour au moins six mois ce qui
est quand même incroyable et moi je
m'attendais pas à ce que l'état soit
aussi rapide et puis derrière c'est
comme pour la crise du co lead les les
mères étaient déjà en train de fabriquer
des masques dans les gymnases quand
l'état est pas encore réquisitionner des
masques chirurgicaux
bon là on est sûr effectivement des élus
qui partout en france et notamment dans
les petites villes se sont mobilisés
quand l'état arrive en deuxième rideau
mais ça se met en place mais on s'est
fait on en a fait on est en train de
faire sur les avoir il ya toujours des
avions qui arrivent en france qui sont
toujours accueillis on l'a fait sur les
irakiens les syriens et on voit que des
villes qui ont eu notamment l'expérience
de ses programmes depuis quelques années
va sont parfaitement outillé pour pour
accueillir des populations déplacées
ukrainienne restez avec nous et j'ai pas
mal de questions à vous poser vincent
chauvet ans je reviendrai vers vous dans
un instant mais j'aurais que fanni comme
qui nous rejoignent tout de suite sur ce
plateau bonsoir fanny bien bienvenue
puisque effectivement on va parler de
ceux de ce statut particulier pour les
réfugiés au crédit avec effectivement
selon les chiffres donnés cet après midi
par jean castex et bien on compte
aujourd'hui en france près de 26 mille
réfugiés ukrainien et en europe et bien
ces réfugiés ukrainiens peuvent
bénéficier d'un statut spécifique c'est
le statut européen de protection
temporaire temporaires dont vous avez
parlé à l'instant la protection
temporaire c'est un dispositif prévu par
l'article 5 de la directive européenne
du 20 juillet 2001 ce statut a été
adopté suite à la guerre en
ex-yougoslavie et le 4 mars dernier est
bien le conseil européen a décidé dans
le mettre en oeuvre et c'est donc la
première fois que ce statut est utilisé
un depuis plus de vingt ans donc après
sa création pour bénéficier de cette
protection temporaire il faut simplement
avoir la nationalité ukrainienne ensuite
donc ces ukrainiens et leurs familles
bénéficient de ce statut pour six mois
renouvelables jusqu'à trois ans le 8
mars dernier le ministre de l'intérieur
à gérald darmanin était auditionné par
la commission des lois du sénat la
commission des affaires européennes il
était interrogé sur cette crise et sur
ce statut vous proposer l'écouté
pour les pays d'accueil parce que les
ukrainiens n'ont pas vocation sauf
évidemment
difficultés géopolitiques majeurs qui va
durer des années mais ce sont tous que
la paix revienne en ukraine
nous pensons que l'échelle d'années qui
nous épargne pas la protection
temporaire nous permet d'imaginer une
solution malgré tout politique à cette
situation évidemment militaire
particulièrement difficile et n'est pas
comparable avec ce qui se passe en syrie
ou en afghanistan et que des ukrainiens
eux mêmes ont vocation à retourner en
ukraine c'est ce qu'ils demandent en
premier et donc il nous fallait un
système de protection qui ressemblait à
l'asile mais qui n'était pas l'asile qui
était beaucoup plus loin à obtenir
puisque la production temporaire sera
beaucoup plus rapide vu que les
événements que nous connaissons sont
soudain et sont évidemment
il était en tout cas imprévisible au
cours de cette audition le ministre a
notamment évoqué le nombre de places
d'accueil disponibles seront
effectivement donc c'était le 8 mars
dernier selon mise à l'intérieur on
dénombrait alors dit
1798 places d'accueil pour ces personnes
n'ont qu'un l'entendre un jean castex
annoncé que la france sera en mesure en
mesure d'accueillir près de cent mille
réfugiés ukrainien voire plus jean
castex qui donnait cet après-midi le
chiffre de dix mille cinq cent une
craignent un qui ont obtenu un justement
ce statut européen de protection
temporaire concrètement il donne accès à
plusieurs choses et cela dans tous les
pays de l'union européenne un visa un
travail un logement des soins évidemment
avec l'assurance maladie en france
certaines aides sociales et puis ce
statut permet de faire venir les
conjoints les enfants des enfants vous
l'avez dit qu'ils ont accès à l'école en
france alors on rappelle enfin que ces
règles qui encadrent ce statut européen
de protection temporaire ne présentent
qu'une base on se quitte chaque état est
libre de faire plus et en france par
exemple et on sait que la sncf a annoncé
la gratuité des transports pour les
réfugiés le crime merci beaucoup c'est
cette mesure de la sncf ça me fait
réagir folie enfants elle existe déjà
dans d'autres pays l'allemagne la
d'angers a décidé depuis au moins trois
semaines dont on ne fait en fait
qu'imiter des décisions encore été prise
heureusement par d'autres pays mais
c'est très bien c'est un débat est très
bien c'est une bonne décision voilà en
fait on pourrait le faire qu'on aurait
pu le faire trois semaines plus tôt
vincent chauvet il ya combien de
familles ukrainienne déjà chez vous
comment vous combien de familles vous
préparer à accueillir et surtout comment
vous avez fait
nous on a 65 personnes à peu près une
quinzaine de familles principalement des
proches d'autres tu nous on avait une
petite communauté russophone et le
craignait mais il ya aussi d'aider des
russes qui ont souvent de la famille en
ukraine et qui ont participé à l'accueil
à la traduction bénévole il ya la moitié
des enfants aujourd'hui qui sont
scolarisés ça fait une dizaine d'enfants
qui sont scolarisés la fois dans
l'enseignement privé catholique qui a
fait la gratuité des frais d'inscription
et dans l'enseignement public par
rapport à votre diapositives précédente
en france la scolarisation est un droit
inconditionnel quel que soit le statut
des enfants et on n'a pas le droit de
demander la régularité du droit au
séjour pour pour scolariser je sais pas
comment c'est dans les autres pays
européens mais même sans son
autorisation provisoire de séjour il
aurait aidé
reese et quant à la question tout à
l'heure des étudiants bon on à la
question très particulière des étudiants
libanais beaucoup d'étudiants le
libanais notamment faisait des études de
santé en ukraine et et c'est un peu
compliqué de retourner en libye au liban
les autres étudiants peuvent retourner
chez eux quant aux autres dans leur
famille quant aux autres études quant
aux autres étrangers qui étaient en
situation légale en ukraine nous sur 65
personnes on a un arménien et puis un
camerounais donc on est très loin des
chiffres délirants de l'extrême droite
qu'on a pu voir deux de 30% en tout est
dans la population qui a été accueilli à
autun ccl2 sur 65 et bien ces personnes
qui avaient un droit au séjour soit
parce que c'est des conjoints
d'ukrainiens sont parce qu'ils étaient
des travailleurs là bas sont aussi
couverts par l' autorisation provisoire
de séjour donc on laisse pas des gens à
la porte de la france merci pour ce
témoignage on va parler un peu des
enjeux politiques vous avez évoqué
l'extrême droite évidemment on est en
pleine campagne présidentielle
et voilà le cet afflux de réfugiés il a
il a donné lieu à plusieurs prises de
position je vous propose d'écouter
eric zemmour c'était jeudi dernier
moi je veux bien accueillir
temporairement les réfugiés ukrainien
parce qu'ils sont nos frères européens
et chrétiens je ne veux pas que profite
de cela des immigrés africains algérien
etc qui profiterait de sa rente
laetitia 7 cette invasion de l'ukraine
cette question de l'accueil des réfugiés
ça aussi poussé marine le pen à
assouplir son discours en dire ça comme
ça oui alors elle dit dans le fond un
peu ce que dirait xénon finalement mais
pas de la même façon voyez-vous elle a
quand même commencé depuis plusieurs
années ce processus de normalisation
donc elle en profite et elles tirent
profit de cette crise pour effectivement
banaliser sa position mais comme le font
les premiers ministres polonais et
hongrois je vous rappelle que en
novembre ces images-là la frontière de
la biélorussie de l'apologue c'était une
autre d'autres migrants s'était démis
camp qui venait du moyen-orient ça quand
même poser un énorme problème et la
pologne et hongrie ouvrent leurs portes
parce que ce sont des voisins immédiats
et parce que effectivement ils ont
décidé de changer totalement leur
discours leur image leur positionnement
emmanuel macron non marine le pen fait
exactement la même chose et donc elle
brandit à dans toutes les interviews la
convention de genève comme un peu le
sésame pour dire il faut accueillir tous
les ukrainiens mais quand on lui demande
pourquoi son parti avait refuser
l'accueil des syriens qui eux aussi sont
protégés par la convention de genève
écoutez ce qu'elle répond
dette on se prive aujourd'hui
d'accueillir précisément dans des
conditions dignes des gens qui pour le
coup corresponde exactement se dire au
statut de réfugié de guerre géré les
ukrainiens y a pas de discussion
possible ils sont véritablement des
réfugiés de guerre on le voit d'ailleurs
ce sont des femmes des enfants des
personnes âgées qui fut la guerre mais
at on aujourd'hui les moyens d'en
accueillir cent mille dans des bonnes
conditions compte tenu du fait que notre
pays a accueilli de manière anarchique
et massive
et migrants du monde entier bah ça n'est
même pas sûr et c'est bien triste parce
qu'en fait les vrais réfugiés sans du
coup je pense les victimes du laxisme
des dernières années alors elle
répondait également qu'en fait les
syriens étaient en majorité des hommes
qui profitait de cet exode pour
s'installer durablement en france c'est
pour cela que nous en avons parlé en
début de plateau or c'est faux puisque
environ 40% des demandes de protection
venant des syriens a été fait par des
femmes et france info à décrypter tout
tout ce que disait marie le pen je vous
invite à aller le voir et vous voyez
avec son discours d'un peu à hannut ans
est finalement mais alors si on l'entend
les ukrainiens seraient plus acceptable
oui c'est ce comme disait eric zemmour
finalement et elle ne dit pas européen
et chrétiens elle dit juste européen
c'est aussi faux mais bon voilà en tout
cas elle a trouvé ce terme pour
entièrement lacé plus acceptable et bien
sûr évidemment son discours la serre on
est à moins de trois semaines du premier
tour elle et quand encore une fois dans
ce processus de banalisation et ces
points là thomas compte double alors
vous êtes nombreux à vouloir réagir mais
je commence avec vous gérard françois
dumont oui je voudrais peut-être un peu
nuancer l'idée que la hongrie ou la
pologne aurait changé à la suite de
cette invasion par la russie de
l'ukraine en réalité bien avant cette
invasion ces deux pays avaient des
relations très étroites avec l'ukraine
et en particulier en pologne avait plus
d'un million et demi d'ukrainiens et ils
étaient accueillis je veux dire tous les
jours et sans problème donc il n'y a pas
eu un changement de dollars de la part
de la hongrie moi j'ai eu l'occasion par
exemple de me rendent à debrecen qui est
la deuxième ville de hongrie à l'est de
la hongrie les relations de l'est de la
hongrie avec l'ukraine sont extrêmement
étroites et quand vous arriviez à cette
gare de debrecen qu'elle était l'endroit
où il y avait le plus de monde eh bien
c'était le guichet où il fallait changer
son argent ukrainien pour de l'argent
permettant d'acheter eux en gris donc
pour moi si vous laissez pas vraiment un
changement significatif
simplement d'existence de cette diaspora
explique en outre leur capacité
d'accueil mais ça pose tout le blême de
l'union européenne puisqu'il serait
quand même assez normal justement côté
de la solidarité les pays qui
accueillent le plus craignant doit aider
par l'union européenne et de même que
les merdes à mon sens signer si le les
maires devraient aussi est aidé par le
gouvernement alors que vous savez que
dans le plan résilience et à zéro
centime pour les communes mais je vais
mettre les pieds dans le plat dans dans
cette histoire pardon mais moi j'ai le
sentiment que c'est plus facile
d'accueillir les ukrainiens parce qu'ils
sont blancs et chrétiens
ce que dit avec ses mots ben oui c'est
moi ça explique peut-être que je vais
vous choquer mais ça explique aussi les
83 % de français qui disent oui il faut
accueillir les réfugiés chrétiens je ne
peux pas faire l'impasse sur le fait que
30% de 30% des français
vont peut-être voter et eric zemmour et
où marine le pen
mais c'est pas la
convention dure mais je ne faisais la
plupart des pays un jour
avoir dans les langues générosité fait
pas autant
non religieux je dis pas comme je dis
pas que la convention de genève en cela
je ne dis pas que moi j'en fais je dis
que dans la réaction d'une partie de
l'opinion aux fontenelles devons
combattre cela me
faisait comme si non on ne fait pas
comme si ça n'existait pas avant fin moi
en tout cas je ne le vois pas du tout
comme ça c'était ce que ce que j'ai vu
et ce qui m'a réellement
arrêter vraiment arrêter c'est quelque
chose chez les franchises tous ces
français qui ont exprimé un élan de
fraternité pour les ukrainiens
qui plus que ça qui ont pris leur
voiture le vendredi soir qu'ils sont
allés à part celui de chercher et c'est
quand même hallucinant sans parler un
mot de russe
c'est que j'ai retrouvé
quelque chose que j'avais quasiment
perdu c'est que les il a une dimension
politique
oui le créatif en valeur nos valeurs
démocratiques et donc il ya une partie
de cette réaction il ya une dimension
politique de l'asile les français on
agit ils n'ont pas réagi ils n'ont pas
exprimé de l'émotion ce ne sont pas des
enfants qui quittent la coupe ils ont
ils ont aj ils ont agi ils ont même agir
sans savoir comment cette histoire
allait finir il choses m'intéressent
aussi chez les français et que je ne
sens pas je n'entends pas dans le
discours d'un monsieur zemmour de madame
le pen et qui pourtant se prétendent six
français il ya quelque chose qui moi
étrangères orgue à laquelle je suis
extrêmement sensible chez les français
c'est cette capacité de se montrer
fraternelle
pour n'importe qui or les ukrainiens
pour les français c'est n'importe qui
nous n'avons pas de rapports extrêmement
précis avec les ukrainiens les yeux
juste à kaboul la ja cols étaient les
bons repris kaboul et dans toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion il y avait une
inquiétude majoritaire dans l'opinion
publique française de l'arrivée
d'afghans laisser mon massive et donc
vous voyez bien la direction c'est pas
la même culture laisser visibles
peut-être que c'est c'est fou mais on
est dans l'imaginaire collectif
ça n'a pas du tout le même impact du
tout voilà c'est ce nez et ça n'est pas
la sauce années de
désaccords mais le parlement la même
chose nous nous lavons si nous regardons
quelle a été la principale migration
dans le monde avant celle de nicolas
jours c'est celle du venezuela avec 5
millions benzema qui ont quitté ce pays
eh bien on a bien vu les efforts qui ont
été faits par la colombie notamment et
les autres pays voisins pour les
accueillir sereinement parce qu'il
considérait que ces venezuela était un
peu de leur même culture est d'ailleurs
déjà ce la même langue je vous laisse
finir à lésiner ensemble de paramètres
culturels il a fallu rapidement ce nom
ce qui m'a frappé dans l'accueil des
ukrainiens c'est devoir s'activer se
réveiller en france des mémoires d'exode
de
migration des parents des grands parents
ça ce sont les histoires que j'ai
entendu parmi le réseau notamment par
exemple les français d'origine russe
polonaise roumaine oui et c deja qui se
sont réveillés parce que leurs parents
leurs grands parents leurs arrière
grands parents avaient vécu quelque
chose de similaire c'est ça un peuple
voisin de maillet et la fraternité des
lancers
mais je les ai vu une chose c'est banal
c'est que les valeurs de l'union
européenne ne sont pas à géométrie
variable et que bien sûr j'entends le
paramètre dans le jeu mais vous avez
raison de constater mais c'est une
meilleure je constate que la hongrie et
la pologne
au paradou refuser absolument toute
répartition des réfugiés sur leur
territoire et qu'ils sont rentrés en
conflit de manière très forte avec le
reste de plus dur est parti seul au but
mais aujourd'hui ils ne demandent pas de
répartition mais attention à
au discours qui est diffusée aujourd'hui
dans l'opinion publique par une extrême
droite très puissante et qui tend
effectivement à faire cette différence
il y à aujourd'hui en france un certain
nombre de gens qui sont réfugiées et
qu'ils estiment
être
traité différemment des réfugiés
ukrainien si vous aller du côté de
briançon si vous aller du côté de calais
vous avez un certain nombre de gens avec
des situations extrêmement
délicate précaire où les gens ne sont
pas prises en charge et le devoir d
humaniste le devoir des européens c'est
de faire en sorte que ces valeurs
s'applique toujours bien tout le temps
et nous devrons le rappeler nous devrons
le rappeler à la pologne et à la hongrie
une fois le conflit terminé mot de
conclusion pour vous david robert je
reprends ce que disait rien de ce
roadster est ce qu'on peut espérer que
finalement le regard sur les réfugiés
change durablement grâce à cette crise
ukrainienne je pense que c'est sans
doute une des rares consolations de
cette crise qu'on est en droit de
prévoir tout à fait pour nous joindre à
elles deux choses puisque vous montrer
cette conclusion la première c'est de
rappeler que pour je dirais pouvoir
bâtir un socle de cet élan citoyen il
faut sans doute dire aussi que
accueillant n'a pas la charge mentale de
toutes les démarches administratives de
la personne c'est hyper important que
l'accueillant construisent une relations
interculturelles authentique forte qui
lui permettent d'éprouver ce que c'est
que l'accueil et à ce titre là il ya
effectivement les professionnels de
l'accueil qui s'occupe de ce que la
dimension administrative et sociale et
ensuite la réalité cette relation que
les français vont vivre avec les
ukrainiens qu'ils accueillent je pense
que ça c' est le fait d'éprouver cet
accueil c'est quelque chose que nous on
voit dans les premières réunions
d'information qu'on mène avec les
familles accueillantes tel jeudi dernier
jouvray à marseille
l'exclusion répétée à redon un mot de
conclusion à une volée en disant on
voudrait accueillir des gens l'ukrainien
et on leur disait vous savez il ya des
gens qui viennent du soudan et des al
chemist anciens bolides attentes et vous
avez d'abord accueillir ces gens là et
90% des gens nous disaient bien
évidemment où avais je la tête oui
effectivement c'est accueillir un
enseignant quelqu'un dont c'est la même
chose d'important c'est d'accueillir
donc je pense que oui
permettre de changer un peu à l'écart
c'est merci on va terminer sur sur ce
message d'espoir merci beaucoup à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat gérard
françois dumont rappel le titre de votre
livre géographie des populations c'est
publié aux éditions armand colin